all right well we've got a little time
before the tail end of this system is
out of here we might even get a few
sprinkles around because the clouds are
still somewhat heavy and we've still got
a little bit of snow in the mountains
temperatures are cool in the 40s and
we've got a few Southwest breezes at
times out especially out at Red Rock but
some neighborhoods a little breeze up 10
15 miles an hour and that's going to
make it feel extra cool pahrump's in the
30s we've got low 30s at Indian Springs
and we've got 40s up there in Mesquite
this morning so kiddos grab a nice warm
jacket this morning somewhat cloudy and
cool this afternoon we should have
mostly sunny skies with mid 50s but even
that's below normal when that afternoon
bell rings and you're getting ready to
leave for the bus or riding your bike
home or the walk so now at the tail end
of this system over Southern Nevada but
it is pulling way into Arizona and the
Four Corners bringing snow to the
Rockies we'll take a break for a couple
of days the next systems coming out of
British Columbia it's coming out of
Canada so it's going to bring a lot of
cold air with it and our snow levels are
going to die 5 a lot lower than what
they've been over the last couple of
weeks there's been some pretty good snow
around Interstate 40 thunderstorms
around Tucson snow over the Northwest
Arizona but again we're just about done
with this system but man did it bring
some nice rain officially it brought
another thirteen hundredths of an inch
for us that puts us at two-thirds of an
inch but some of the rain totals have
been great spring mountains two
two-thirds of an inch Lone Mountain four
tenths of an inch and various
neighborhoods have picked up over the
course of Saturday and Monday a quarter
of an inch or more but up in the
mountains an inch and a quarter up at
Kyle Canyon Road good Springs almost an
inch of rain Mesquite almost a half an
inch in Boulder City you've seen about a
third of an inch of rain so very
beneficial rains for us 55 for the
afternoon high again a little more
sunshine this afternoon sunny and cool
tomorrow at 52 that next round of rain
on Thursday with cold air could drop
snow levels to 3 000 feet that's below
the Red Rock Visitor Center so we'll see
what happens on Thursday and then we're
just staying extra cool through the
weekend highs in the low 50s and
mornings near freezing